joining us now on the phone is not
Anatolia host for a national radio
network based in the new zealand city of
Auckland
she has been covering the shooting since
the beginning Nadia a good morning I
know you've spoken with witnesses what
are they telling you well I must admit
today has been truly harrowing one of
the worst of my 20-year journalism
career it is really unfair thermoball
what has unraveled here today in new
zealand we were indicated and we were
sent invitations early on today at
around 2 p.m. new zealand time that
there were shots fired and inner city
christchurch which is our second largest
city and new zealand population of
around three hundred and seventy
thousand people gunshots in and around a
mosque we weren't sure what was going on
but eyewitness accounts coming in to our
radio station indicated that it was
rapid fire people were screaming people
were yelling what we now know is the
gunman went in there and streamed this
terrible attack there were up to 300
people inside that mosque worshipping
and he unloaded his weapon his automatic
weapon it fired upon all the people
there including men and women and very
young children some of those are
eyewitnesses recounted how they ran into
the mosque after he left he found a
father cradling his daughter who had
been shot he was screaming for
assistance screaming for an ambulance
anything
another gentleman called us and told us
that he'd gone into a bathroom to wash
his hands and in fact he heard the
shooting and revel outside the door he
was calling triple one which is our
emergency line he had to wait 20 minutes
until the police arrived but what he
could hear he said was worse than a
terrorist
they were cold-blooded blooded killers
and he was absolutely petrified so as
you can imagine the entire chaotic event
has been truly harrowing for all of New
Zealand little own the city of
Christchurch Nadia are you suggesting
there was more than one gunman more than
one assailant yes it has actually been
four arrests one person one individual
has in fact been charged with murder and
will appear in Christchurch district
court tomorrow
morning the other three it's still
unclear as to what their involvement was
anything there were rumors or reports
that in fact one of the people involved
just came out with a weapon and that in
fact New Zealand is a country which does
not have weapons I've traveled to the
United States Europe Asia you often see
authorities or police authorities with
weapons you just don't see that here in
New Zealand very really police armed so
it is quite an unusual sight but
certainly we don't know the status of
those other three what we do know is one
man has been charged with murder and
will appear tomorrow in court as we know
he live-streamed this event and as i've
you've just outlined in your reports
he had manifesto which he uploaded
online now this indicates his motives
clearly but as he pointed out he is an
Australian what was truly traumatizing
for our micro workers here was we were
being seen to that livestream video and
to our Facebook and social media
channels and some of the staffers here
were opening up this live feed in
witnessing firsthand this horrendous
account and I can tell you that people
were in tears that it is it was truly
horrible right Nydia toilets thank you
for joining us this morning